ah our health insurance bill is going up
again for what we pay every year we
could add another room on to the house
sheesh you're right it seems like we're
paying more and more for a service we
barely use I mean I do yoga and eat all
my veggies and we hardly ever get sick
now that we're no longer required to
purchase health insurance it makes me
wonder should we be paying for it at all
[Music]
and if we get sick or hurt down the line
we can just use that money to pay the
bill but what if we have a serious
injury like your turkey fryer incident
last Thanksgiving no sweat
we can just crowdsource money for the
bills I see people on Facebook
fundraising for medical costs all the
time great although I do think you
should quit your extreme parkour only if
you quit nice juggling steel
[Music]
how do you ever found yourself wondering
if you should just skip out on this
whole health insurance thing if you
don't have coverage offered through your
job it's a pretty hefty monthly expense
in 2018 the average private insurance
plan cost four hundred and forty dollars
a month for an individual and eleven
hundred and sixty eight dollars per
family coverage for that kind of know I
could afford that trip to Japan or by a
miniature Finnick with the recent repeal
of the individual mandate within the
Affordable Care Act some younger
healthier people might be left wondering
should I pay thousands of dollars each
year for a service I'll probably never
use take Maria here she just graduated
with a master's degree and works for a
tech startup that doesn't offer health
insurance or retirement options she's
making too much to qualify for
subsidized health care so she has to pay
375 dollars a month for her individual
health insurance policy but she's an
avid runner eats mostly organic and
hasn't been sick in five years that
money could be going to her retirement
or savings to buy a house what might
happen to Maria if she decides to cancel
her policy in order to fast track other
financial priorities I think it's time
to if Maria decides to cancel her health
insurance policy she can expect to save
around 4,500 dollars a year but she'll
still prepare for the occasional minor
injury or illness by setting aside a
thousand dollars a year for doctor
visits or occasional urgent care if she
stashes what's left in a CD earning
two-and-a-half percent interest in just
five years she'll have eighteen thousand
eight hundred fifty seven dollars Maria
just has to stay relatively healthy for
the next five years and she's gamed the
system things are going fine for a while
and then in her third year of the plan
Maria is in a serious car auto insurance
would only pay a fraction of her medical
costs now after all the hospital surgery
and the ambulance kills Maria is left
with fifty eight thousand dollars in
medical debt and an additional eight
thousand dollars on credit cards she
used to pair bills while recovering
desperate Maria launches a GoFundMe
campaign joining the two hundred and
fifty thousand other people who use the
platform every year to try
I helped pay medical bills and she ends
up raising the average amount only
$3,000 facing sixty three thousand
dollars in debt her parents decide to
help they take out a line of credit on
their home using the money to pay off
Maria's debts in full two years later
when Maria's dad is forced to retired
because of his own health problems they
fall behind on their mortgage payments
and lose the house granted the chances
of a sudden costly medical problem
hitting someone young and healthy like
Maria are slim but not insignificant a
2011 survey found that people between
the ages of 25 and 34 had a 1 in 10
chance of getting hit with a medical
bill of $13,000 or more and a 1 in 20
chance of at least a $27,000 bill
considering the lifetime of financial
damage that kind of price tag can do to
you or your family these odds are not to
be taken lightly besides the whole point
of insurance is to protect you from
really bad things that probably won't
happen no one buys insurance hoping
they'll get to use it is there a middle
path that Maria could have taken that
would have allowed her to save something
but also be protected against a
catastrophe well she could have enrolled
in a high deductible health plan these
have lower premiums and will help you if
something really bad happens
but don't typically cover routine
medical costs most insurance providers
offer such options and they can be a
good fit for young healthy people but
Maria would still be on the hook for
every day doctor's visits and medication
so she could set aside a thousand
dollars a year for that purpose but put
it into a health savings account which
allows her to deduct the money from her
taxes and anything that's not used for
medical expenses becomes part of her
retirement savings health savings
accounts are available only to people
with high deductible health plans and
can be started at your insurance
providers recommended bank or whatever
your own choosing
imagine if Maria got into that car
accident with
this scenario the most she'd have to pay
out-of-pocket is $4,000 and if she stays
safe and healthy
she'll be stashing money away into her
HSA that could later be used for
retirement and even have a little left
over to start saving for a home
most importantly she knows she's not
putting her financial future or that of
her loved ones in jeopardy and that's
our two cents do you know other creative
solutions to the high costs of health
insurance let us know about them in the
comments
[Music]
you